Ricardo is in Fort Worth Texas hi
Ricardo how are you hey I'm doing great
how are you better than I deserve what's
up so my wife and I are looking to buy
our first house and hearing talk of a
market crash similar to 2008 so were you
hanging around with I heard some Peter
Shiff on a podcast and then my
father-in-law so what do you think about
waiting a bit to see if that happens to
get a better deal on a house I wouldn't
because I don't think it's going to
happen I disagree with the people who
are teaching you listen I've been in the
real estate business since 1978 I got my
real estate license when I turned 18
years old that's almost 40 years how old
are you 25 okay I have only seen one
time one time in my working lifetime
during that almost 50 years now that the
real estate market has gone down in
value so substantially that it took it
more than 12 months to recover okay it
just doesn't happen now what could
happen is the market could get a little
bit softer that could happen in other
words like right now it's really
difficult to buy because there's six
bars for every house right it's like a
bidding war
right which is driving prices up up up
up up up up and up and that kind of
thing so you know that's what you're
facing right now the market could slow
down and I do think that what it
probably will happen at some time in the
future but the 2008 market crash there
is no logical data out there to support
that that's coming again and so I
disagree with whoever's been telling you
this I think that's bad advice and so if
I were 25 years old what would I do I'd
buy a house if you're ready to buy a
house if you're out of debt you have
your emergency fund you have a good
strong down payment you're putting it on
a 15-year fixed and the payments no more
than four three your take-home pay I'd
buy a house
I wouldn't wait because I don't think
they're going anywhere in Fort Worth
Texas but up now will the market slow
down if the interest rates continue to
climb and they have been climbing yeah I
think it'll slow down is it going to
crash so we're gonna experience a two
thousand eight again
no listen here's what's weird okay I got
in the real estate business Ricardo like
I said in nineteen seventy eight you
know what happened that for nineteen
seventy-eight
interest rates went to seventeen percent
by 1981 seventeen percent think about
that you know did the market crash no it
stopped nobody was buying houses but the
weird thing is house prices did not dive
the market went from nine percent
interest rate to seventeen percent can
you imagine my house at seventeen
percent interest
it's like putting house on a credit card
now we sold some houses but they're very
difficult and very few and far between
I was selling real estate in those days
I was in college by the time I got out
of college in 1982 III rates were down
to about fourteen percent and the houses
were selling like crazy again crazy
because everybody been waiting on
interest rates to come down when they
came from 17 down to 14 it caused a
spike in the market can you believe that
so even in that extreme crap house
prices did not dive like they did in
2008 so interest rates or economic
conditions really did not cause the real
estate market to dive in 2008 even what
caused as a dive was the mortgage
company crisis and the market the
financial market crisis which is an
economic crisis of sorts okay so that
get something to stated that but bottom
line is this there are always people out
there who are going to predict the end
of the world there are people who make a
good living predicting the end of the
world the end is coming
the end is coming
and there are always people that do that
there always have been and I've just
made a commitment as a financial guy
unless I see real data that tells me
that I'm not gonna say that and even
then I'm gonna question my own sanity
because I've got a long history in
America of that not being true so if I'm
in your shoes dude I'm buying a house I
think real estates a good investment
could it slow down could it go down yeah
but it'll come back and you will not
have missed the best opportunity ever in
your life to buy that probably was 2008
I bought a lot of real estate when it
was down but I'm you know if I'm ready
to buy real estate today I'm not waiting
on the market to go back down to 2008
levels before I buy I'm gonna buy